>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Karen Jaffe: So, I'm here
to introduce Cathy [inaudible]
who you know, is our consultant
for the team board at the Library
of Congress and Cathy will
introduce Monica Hesse.
>> Cathy: Thank you all for coming
and I know this is
a little different
because we are not reading,
reviewing, doing [inaudible].
I'm OK with that.
So, we still want you
to read [inaudible] copy
of the teens' book, that's great.
So, keep those reviews coming,
but now, the most important part
of today is, Monica Hesse is author
of, "The Girl in the Blue Collar".
And she's also written
two other teen books,
and she's also a writer
to the Washington Post.
So, she has two different
careers going on.
I think she works 24/7 or something.
>> Monica Hesse: 48/7.
>> Cathy: Anyway, I think
[inaudible] enjoy her book,
it's historical fiction
in World War II.
As a girl who is kind of in a
position of having to make a choice
between just kind of
turning the other --
look in the other way or helping
some people that really need help,
Jewish during World War II.
So, Monica, thank you
very much for coming.
>> Monica Hesse: So, I hear some
of you are journalists, yes?
Raise your hand if you
are in a journalist class.
Excellent.
This makes my job so much easier
because I'm going to trust
that when I run out
of things to say,
you guys will be much more
interesting and have lots
of questions to ask me, yes, yes.
That's true.
And you in the back, you are
not journalists' students,
but you are readers, awesome.
OK. So, I work for the Washington
Post, and that's my day job,
it's been kind of crazy year.
How many of you follow politics?
OK. It's been kind of
a crazy year, right?
So, this year I got to do things
like go to political conventions,
in Philadelphia and Cleveland
and that was really interesting
to see the country and what kind
of things people were talking about
and how sometimes it seemed
like people are not even
talking in the same languages.
I also get to do other kind of
stuff, like, I went to the Oscars.
So, I always tell people, if we
can't think of anything to talk
about in the Roman
[phonetic] Historical Fiction,
we can talk about Jennifer
Lopez's but,
because I accidentally touched it
when I was at the Academy Award.
And that is an experience
on to itself.
So, when we have time for questions,
I hope the journalist will ask
me questions about journalism
which I love to talk about.
Is the best job ever.
And, but now we'll start by
talking about this book, this book.
How many of you read Historical
Fiction on a regular basis?
How many of you think it sounds
like a really boring genre?
You won't offend me, OK, yes.
So, here what is really
interesting about history,
it keeps repeating itself, and even
when you think that you are writing
about another time, and you think
that you are researching
another time,
you are actually researching
right now,
you are actually seeing patterns
come out again and again.
I'm going to tell you what this
book is about and then I'm going
to tell you what this
book is really about.
This book is about a teenage girl
who lives in Amsterdam in 1943,
when it has become occupied
by the SS, by Nazis.
So, in every street corner she
goes, there are Nazi guards,
dressed in green, and there are
curfews and she's not allowed
to go out, and people are
disappearing all around her,
because Jewish families are being
taken, and they're being deported
into concentration camps.
And she makes her living
as a black marker worker.
So, in this age, it's impossible
to get things like cigarettes,
and alcohol and chocolate,
and perfumes,
and these sort of luxury goods.
So, my character Hanika [phonetic],
she makes her living by moving
around the city, getting
these goods under the table,
and then selling them for a profit.
And one day, one of her
regular clients asks her
for help finding something
extra special, and is a person.
And her client says -- I've been
hiding this young Jewish girl
in my pantry for the
past couple of months
and she's disappeared,
into thin air.
And so, my character hast to figure
out how to go about searching
for a girl who is not supposed to
exist at all because she's a Jewish
and most of the Jewish in
the city have been deported.
So, that's what the book is about.
Is a mystery about trying
to find a missing person
when you live in a police state.
When the people around you are
being harmed, are being deported.
What the book is really about
is about trying to figure
out how far you would go
to do the right thing,
and how you know what
the right thing is.
And, how do you forgive yourself
when you've been doing the
wrong thing for a long time.
Is about betrayals between friends,
and it's about losing
the first person
that you love in a permanent way.
And raise your hand if you
think like me, whenever I think
about the Holocaust before writing
this book, I would always think,
I would have been one of the people
who was a part of the resistance,
like obviously I would
have volunteer,
I would have helped hide people,
I would have been a part of that.
Yes? I think is like --
it's so easy to think that.
And here is what's
fascination, it was really hard
to be a part of the resistance.
You would be imprisoned,
you could be killed,
your family would definitely
loose it's livelihood.
If you are a character
like my character,
Hanika who supports her family,
being part of the resistance
would probably mean poverty
and homeliness for your family.
And so, what I think is really
fascinating is that is so easy
to say what we think we would
do, and then, when we are put
to the test, would
we really do that?
And I think about that now, when
we talk about things like --
when we talk about things
like Syrian refugees,
should we accept Syrian
refugees into the country?
Because they were having
that discussion 80 years ago
about whether we should accept
Jewish refugees into the country.
When we talk about,
would we stand up
and protect people
of different faith?
Would we stand up for our
Muslims brothers or sisters?
They were having that
conversation 80 years ago,
but it was about the Jewish
people who lived among them.
So, I totally get that reading
Historical Fiction can seem just
so [inaudible] and boring, but
I feel like you are reading
about people, no matter
where people lived,
and that's what I like about it.
For those of you who actually
like Historical Fiction,
do you have any recommendations?
Did you raise your hand?
What do you like?
>> The book?
>> Monica Hesse: Yes, or the
genre or the era, or the time.
[inaudible].
Oh, what's that about?
>> It's about a girl [inaudible]
country and she [inaudible]
but she has [inaudible] she lives
with a forest parent
[inaudible] school [inaudible] how
to write and read [inaudible].
>> Monica Hesse: Oh my Gosh,
that does sound amazing.
How else wants to read that book?
I do. OK. does anyone else have
any favorites before we start?
No? All right, yes, you.
>> A boy in a [inaudible].
>> Monica Hesse: Oh,
that's really good.
And that's also World War II.
Yes, that's a great book.
Thank you for recommending that.
So, here's what I thought that
I would do and you guys tell me
if you have a different way,
you do this more than I do,
you are here all the time.
Tell me if I'm breaking any rules.
I thought that I would read you
a couple of pages form my book,
so you have that kind of a better
sense who the characters are.
And then I want to tell you a
little bit more about how I came
out with those characters, if
there are writers in this room,
sometimes coming with
characters is really hard.
So, I wanted to pass through some
historic photos that gave me kind
of a context and background.
And then, we'll do
questions and we can talk
about whatever you
want for questions.
Does that sound?
Yes? No? OK.
So, I've got more thumps
up than thumps down,
that's what we are going to do.
I'm going to steal this book,
because I forgot to bring my own,
so, is lucky that one
is sitting right here.
So, like I said, this book, it opens
with this named character, Hanika,
who has just been asked by this
client, Mrs. Johnson [phonetic]
to find this young girl
who's going missing.
So, I'm going to read you, just
a couple of pages form just
after this request has been asked.
OK.
Mrs. Johnson is still
waiting for me to respond,
standing in the dark space,
where the air [inaudible]
and smells [inaudible] old potatoes.
Hanika, she asks -- you
were hiding someone?
-- I can barely get the words out
as she relishes the secret shelve,
closes the secret pantry door
and lead me back to the table.
I don't know if I'm more
shocked or more scared.
I know this happens, that some of
the Jews who disappear are packed
like winter [inaudible] in
other people's basements,
rather than relocated to work camps,
but it's too dangerous
to ever admit out loud.
Mrs. Johnson is nodding to my
question -- I was -- in here?
You were hiding someone in here?
For how long?
-- Where should I begin?
-- she says, picking up her napkin
and twisting it between her hands --
I don't really want her to begin at
all, ten minutes ago I was worried
that Mrs. Johnson might have
called someone to arrest me,
but now I know she was the
one who could be arrested.
The punishment for hiding people
is imprisonment, a cold damn cell,
where I've heard of people
disappearing for months
without even getting hearings.
And the punishment
for being a person
in hiding is immediate deportation
-- never mind -- I said quickly --
never mind, I don't need to
hear anything, I'll just go -- .
Why don't you sit down again?
-- She pleads -- I've been
waiting all morning for you --
she holds a pitcher
of coffee -- More?
You can have as much
as you like, just sit,
if you don't help mem I'll
have to find someone else --
And now I'm conflicted, standing
here in the middle of the kitchen
as Mrs. Johnson tries
to find someone else,
she could be putting
herself in danger
and me too -- Tell me what happened?
-- I said finally -- My husband's
business partner -- she begins --
he was a good man, David, he
worked for Hendric [phonetic]
for ten years, he had a wife,
and they had two daughters,
Leah [phonetic] who has just
turned 12 and was the family pet
and the older daughter,
15, independent,
always off with her
friends, Miriam [phonetic] --
her throat catches
at that last name,
and she swallows before continuing
-- the [inaudible] were Jewish,
they are not very observant, and in
the beginning it seemed like that
that would make a difference,
they didn't of course.
In July after the big [inaudible]
where so many Jewish were taken,
David came to Hendric and said he
and his family needed help going
into hiding, -- and
Hendric brought them here?
-- I asked -- No, he didn't want
to put me in danger -- she says --
he brought them to the furniture
shop, he built a [inaudible],
a secret room behind the
false wall in the wooden shop.
I didn't even know
-- you didn't know?
-- I say -- I can't imagine my
own parents being able to keep
such a secret from each other -- I
knew Hendrix was spending more time
in the shop, but I thought he
was just working longer hours,
I thought the [inaudible] had gone
to a safe house in the country,
I didn't know all of them
were right there in hiding --
when did he finally tell you?
-- I asked -- He never told me.
Last month, I was home alone
when I heard knocking at my door,
[inaudible] knocking,
it was after curfew,
I thought Hendrix had
forgotten his key,
but when I opened the
door there was this girl,
this pale girl wearing a blue
coat, she'd grown so much,
I hadn't seen her in a few years,
and I wouldn't have recognized her
if she hadn't introduced herself,
she told me that my husband
had been hiding them,
but now she needed a new safe space,
she said that everyone
else was dead -- .
OK, so, that's sort of near
the beginning of the book.
And so, here is what we know,
we know that this girl appeared
out of nowhere and then she
disappeared into nowhere,
and we have to figure out where
she went, and that is going
to involve going all around
the city of Amsterdam.
So, I wanted to show you
some pictures of Amsterdam,
because I'm kind of a nerd,
and I really like [inaudible]
these photos.
You know I was talking about trying
to figure out why you would do
in a situation, would
you be on the good side?
Would you not?
When I first started to
do research for this book,
this was the first photo
that I came across.
Photos are all messed up.
I'm going to find them.
OK, so, this photo that
I'm going to pass around,
you'll see it has groups of people
walking in the street and some
of them are walking
on the side walk,
and some of them are
walking in the middle.
You guys pass up, and
we'll meet in the middle.
So, what's happening is that this
group of people in the middle,
that's a group of Jewish people
who are being walked to
a deportation center.
And when I say a deportation center,
you guys know the Kennedy's
Center here in D.C.?
OK. So, in Amsterdam, there
was a really famous theater,
called the Dutch Theater.
And, during the time
of World War II,
that became the deportation center.
So, picture the Kennedy
Center, except, instead of going
to see a place there, they rounded
it up every one of a certain faith
and they sent them
there until they started
to take them to concentration camps.
So, what's happening in this
picture is that the group of people
in the middle -- did
anyone not see these?
OK. So, the group of people in the
middle, these are Jewish people
who are being walked to the
center, and these people
on the sides, who are they?
>> Nazis?
>> Monica Hesse: No,
they are you and me.
These are regular people, they are
going about their Sunday business,
and imagine you are out on Sunday,
you are like going shopping,
and next to you there are
groups of people being walked
to the Kennedy Center, which
is now a deportation center
where everyone goes and they
disappear and they don't come back.
And I thought that this
was so interesting,
because this is happening like
right in front of people's eyes.
You know that your
neighbors are disappearing,
they are disappearing right in
front of you, but you have to figure
out what am I going to do about it?
Because like I said, is really
dangerous to do anything about it.
So, I really wanted to write a book
from the perspective of someone
who was in that position, no
that it was happening to her,
the bad stuff is happening
all around her,
and she has to decide whether or
not she's going to act or not.
And so, the main character,
Hanika, that's her,
she's one of those
people, just walking alone,
while bad stuff is happening and
she has to decide what to do.
So, when I started to research,
I also started to learn
about the different kinds of
resistance activities there were,
and this I thought was
really interesting,
because this is a resistance
activity, that was taken up by a lot
of young people, especially
a lot of young women.
And when I say young --
like your age, maybe.
Somehow, I lost --
there it go, thank you.
So, this photo, I'm going to pass
around, this is a teenage girl,
she's caring a purse, you
might notice something off
about the purse, the first person
who sees it -- someone
said it already.
did you say it?
>> There is a camera.
>> Monica Hesse: There's
a camera in the purse.
So, this girl was a part of
the resistance called the
"illegal camera" and
the "illegal camera".
Does everyone see it?
Do can see the lens in the bottom.
What she did, her form of
resistance, she decided was going
to be to document what
was happening.
So, when the secret police
arrested people and beat people
up on the streets, she was
going to take photographs of it.
Does that remind anyone of
anything happening today?
You are nodding your head,
what are you thinking?
[inaudible].
It reminded me of that too,
it reminded me of how we see,
when we see acts of violence we
see people taking photographs.
Did I pass the wrong photos?
I'm losing my mind.
Am I still sitting on the photos?
Thank you.
And I thought that that was really
meaningful is that here is a person
that -- she's young, she
probably doesn't have a house
to hide people in, but she's decided
that her form of resistance is going
to be to document it, is
going to be to say, later on,
if you try to tell a different
story, if you try to say
that something else happened, I am
here to tell you that this happened,
and I can prove that it did,
because here are photographs.
And I thought that that was so
powerful, that 80 years ago,
people are thinking about
this as their form of protest.
So, last photograph that
I'm going to pass around --
so remember I told you
about that Kennedy Center,
like a deportation center?
This is a picture of that,
this is the back alley,
this is the back alley of
that -- of that theater.
And, this photograph was taken not
by the girl whose picture
I just showed you,
but by a very similar --
by a similar young girl.
This photograph was
taken by a girl who lived
in the apartment falling
behind the theater.
And she looked up one day, and she
knew it was a deportation center,
and every day she would see
new groups of people come in,
and one day, she looked up,
and she saw her best friend,
her best friend was Jewish, and
had disappeared from the school,
and suddenly there she was, in
the alley, behind the theater.
And there was nothing the
photographer could do.
Her name is Lidia [phonetic].
There was nothing that Lidia could
do, except photograph her friend,
and say, "this is the
last time that I saw her".
And her friend did not survive.
Her friend was killed
in a concentration camp.
But, I thought that this
photo was really powerful,
and the girl who's circled
in the photo, if you see it,
is just kind of blurry, but the
circled girl, is who I picture
when I picture Myriam [phonetic] the
girl that everyone is trying to find
in my book, which is this girl who
was there, and suddenly she wasn't.
So, I probably talked way
more than you wanted to know
about occupied Amsterdam in
the 1940s, but I think --
like I said, I think that when
we are talking about history,
we are really talking about
human behavior, which is,
which is the same through
the decades.
Again, and again, we see
people making the same mistakes
and struggling with the same issues.
So, I'd love to open
it up for questions,
and they could be questions about
the Netherlands or about writing
or about books, or -- instead
of asking questions you could
just tell me some things
that I should be reading
or learning about,
give me some ideas
for my next stories.
I'd definitely take that too.
Yes?
>> So, I've never really studied
[inaudible] like the Jewish people.
>> Monica Hesse: Oh Gosh, that is
such an enormous question that,
that people write whole books
about it, but, essentially,
have you heard of Adolf Hitler?
>> Yes.
>> Monica Hesse: OK.
So, after World War I,
the country of Germany was
in a really bad way economically,
a lot of people couldn't find jobs,
a lot of people couldn't
find work, and basically,
this man Adolf Hitler rose to power
by using the escape code [phonetic]
of the Jewish people, by saying,
"the reason that we can't --
the reason that the country is
struggling is the Jewish people,
they took all of your jobs, they are
doing better than you financially",
they became an escape code,
until the whole country in a kind
of mass frenzy bought into
it, and they were persecuted
in a really [inaudible] basis.
And if anyone else has also studied
the Holocaust, and has a better way
to describe it in a short hand way,
I'd love to -- please,
please, jump in.
All right.
Yes?
>> I have a question about writing.
How does it feel to
read your own book?
Because whenever I read
mine, I always [inaudible].
>> Monica Hesse: It's
the worst, isn't it?
Like every time I read
anything, I think,
"this is the dumbest thing
anyone has ever written,
why did I do it this way?".
So, the bad news is,
it never changes.
The good news is that we are often
our own worst critics, and also,
the more times you read something,
the more things you notice
that you would change.
But most people are only going
to read what you write,
you know, once or twice.
So, remind yourself of that, you are
reading something for the 12th time,
and most people are not going
to be as nearly as critical.
Yes. Is anyone else a writer?
Who know what I'm talking about?
Yes, OK. How do you feel
when you read your work?
>> When I read the
stuff that I write,
is like every time I read it
[inaudible] I can read it once,
and notice it the first
time, but then,
[inaudible] I notice
something different
>> Monica Hesse: I know, and by
the tenth time, you are like,
haven't I not noticed at all, but is
like, no, you never noticed it all,
there's always something
you would change.
What do you think?
>> I actually agree, for me is
the same way, I just keep trying
to change it to make it
better, then I'm [inaudible].
>> Monica Hesse: Yes, yes.
So, the only good news
that I have to say is,
I've interviewed some really,
really, famous writers and they --
like Nobel -- like Pulitzer
prize winning writers,
and they all feel the same way,
is not just us, is everyone,
everyone doesn't like what
they write when they write it.
But, we just learn to let it go
and no other people are
sometimes better judges
of our work thank we are.
>> Were you always
passionate about writing?
>> Monica Hesse: No, not really.
You know, I got into
journalism because I have --
I really get really nervous
when I have to talk to people,
I can get really uncomfortable,
and I though journalism would
be a good way to force me
to have to talk to people.
And if I could just do all
of my reporting and stuff,
and never actually have to
write, that would be awesome,
but unfortunately,
nobody pays you for that.
So, the writing just became the
thing that I had to do in order
to get to have those
other experiences.
Yes. Are you -- do you
like the writing part
or the interviewing part
of journalism better?
[Inaudible].
What do you like about it?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Monica Hesse: Yes.
But then, sometimes I feel like
when you have had a really good
interview, when you really
feel like you've learned a lot,
those are the stories that I
feel the most stressed out about,
you know, because, you are like,
I really want to do this justice,
this person was really
interesting, am I good enough?
Am I good enough to write that?
So, I don't know, if you have any
advice, I'd welcome that advice.
Oh, yes.
>> Did you enjoy writing your book?
>> Monica Hesse: So,
I did and I didn't.
When you guys write, I'm
always curious to know
about people's processes,
do you always start writing
from the beginning of
whatever you are working on,
or do you ever start other places?
>> The beginning for me.
>> I start from the top and
then go backwards [inaudible].
What I want the book to be about.
>> Monica Hesse: And then you
like fill things in as you go?
Yes.
>> I usually start with
a character design,
because usually my book ideas,
either sometimes I'd just
have an idea for something
that I thought would be really cool
or, I'd have an idea of a person
that I thought would
be really interesting,
and I'd design the character to
the smallest detail as if like,
if they have glasses how they put
on their glasses, or, and then,
from that, I design
a story around them.
>> Monica Hesse: Yes.
So, I think that I'm most like
you, where I'd think of a scene,
maybe like a mixture of the two
of you, where I'll have a scene
that I really want to write
and the character I really want
to write about, and so,
I'll write that scene,
and then I'll write other
scenes as I think of them.
So, this is a long way of saying,
the beginning of the writing,
is really, really, fun
because I'm writing the things
that came naturally.
But then later, when you have to go
and fill in the rest, is like, oh,
there is a reason, that
I saved this until last,
because it's really hard,
because I don't know how to do it.
So, it's fun in the
beginning, and then,
at the end I would give anything
to have it be over with, I think.
Anyone else?
OK. Wait, OK.
You asked one already,
so you go first.
>> We went to the political
convention -
[ Inaudible ]
>> Monica Hesse: Yes.
So, someone asked this I
was in a class earlier today
and I've been thinking about
how to have a better answer,
but the broadest way that
I can describe is that,
it just really felt like going into
two completely different universes.
It was like visiting two different
countries, and people were not,
people seemed to be afraid of
completely different things,
and be talking about
completely different things.
I read this study a few days ago
that I thought was completely
fascinating which said that --
it was all about like what Democrats
buy versus what Republicans buy.
And, like they don't even buy
the same laundry detergent,
and they don't even
go to the same movies.
Like, I was reading that Democrats
are 97 percent more likely
to go see horror movies, the
Republicans are something
like 80 percent more likely
to go see romantic comedies.
And, I think that that's a
really scary and weird snapshot
of the country right now, if we are
not even going to the same movies,
what can we talk about, what kind
of common ground can
we find to talk about?
And that's kind of what struck me
about the political
conventions is that, you had -
You were talking to groups of
people who really passionly believe
in what they believed
in, and they were in kind
of different planets
from each other.
So, after you finish up your school
work tonight, figure out a way
to fix the country
and get back to me,
and let me know what
you figured out.
Did you have a question?
>> Yes, what advice
would you give to people
who want to become writers?
>> Monica Hesse: So,
the first advice --
there's really only like one piece
of advice, and that is to write,
which sounds really basic, but is
amazing how many people I meet,
grown up people, who are
like, "I'm a writer",
but then when you ask
what they are writing,
they are like, "I might write x".
And I sort of believe, that if you
are a writer, you should be writing,
you should be writing all the time.
And, the thing is -- I think a lot
of people think they can't write,
until they have like
a really good idea,
or until they know how it ends,
or until they know how it's going
to go -- and that's
just not true at all.
Most of what you write on any given
day is going to be really bad,
because most of what any of us write
on any given day is really bad.
And I'll have days when
I get up the next day,
read what I wrote the day before
and delete three fourths of it.
And that's OK.
It doesn't -- your first
path doesn't have to be good,
it's just what you want to do
is get yourself in the habit
where you are doing it every day,
so that when you don't do it,
it feels like you forgot to brush
your teeth, or feels like you forgot
to wear underwear, it just has
to be like, "I write everyday
because is part of
planned on what I do",
and getting good at
it, that comes later.
Sometimes that doesn't
come until a lot later.
But, there are zero shortcuts,
you just kind of have to do it.
Sorry.
>> I just wanted to ask you, what
made you decide on this period
of time in your book, World War II?
>> Monica Hesse: Yes.
So, I read the Diary of Ann Frank
a lot when I was growing up.
Have any of you read the
Dairy of Anna Franck?
OK, yes, half of you.
So, that book is set in
Amsterdam from 1942 to 1944,
but it all takes place
from inside of one room.
And as I got older, I realized
that I had read this book probably
ten times, but most of what I knew
about the city was from
within one room looking out,
and I was just really curious to
know what the city would have looked
like to someone living
on the outside
and someone trying to
navigate the streets.
[Inaudible].
Yes, I have.
Yes. Anyone else?
Yes
>> So, you say [inaudible].
>> Monica Hesse: Left, left, OK.
>> So, you say you write all the
time, are you writing anything
that you are planning
on getting published?
>> Monica Hesse: Yes.
I just finished a book.
My next book is for adults, and it's
nonfiction, is about an arsonist,
is a true crime and
nothing at all like this.
But, after that, I'm going to
start next month on a book,
another book that's YA
[phonetic] and it's set in 1943,
but in America, it's set in
an internment [phonetic] camp
in the United States
that had Japanese
and German prisoners living in it.
Yes. [Inaudible].
What? No. It's this little town
called Cristal City, Texas,
and the whole town basically
became an internment camp.
[Inaudible].
Yes, yes. Like they --
I mean, America was not
sodly [phonetic] heroic,
during World War II, and we
rounded up a lot of own citizens.
So, this book is about some of
the immigrant characters who ended
up being in this internment
camp during the war.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Monica Hesse: I don't think
I'll ever write a sequel, I mean,
I think I know what happens
to the characters, but,
I feel like they were left at a
pretty complete place in the end.
And, I mean I think if I did do
a sequel, it wouldn't be about --
there are a few characters in this
book who are really pretty minor,
but in my mind, I know a lot
more about their back story
and find them really interesting.
So, it would focus
on those characters,
rather than the essential ones.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Monica Hesse: OK.
So, before I answer, I'm so
curious about that question.
Does anyone else have any --
does anyone else have
experience with this?
And what do you guys do?
You never talk to people
you disagree with?
Come on.
>> Monica Hesse: Yes, yes.
You are right, because the
difference when you are a journalist
as opposed to when you are taking
to a friend, you are right,
I can't be like, well I think that's
wrong, because that's not my job.
But, you know, I think that
the interviews when I'm talking
to someone who makes no sense to me,
are the most interesting interviews,
because I'm trying
so hard to understand
where they are coming from, and why
their position makes sense to them,
and what went into making
them have this position,
that I feel like it's
not hard for me to --
I never want to tell the
them that they are wrong,
because that's not my job.
My job is just to try to understand
like -- where does this come from,
and why do you think this way?
And how can I explain
this to readers in a way
that will hopefully help us
understand each other a little bit
more, you know, rather than
just having everyone see
like a caricature or like a
cartoon, or a -- you know --
I saw a lot of, "I defriended all of
the Trump's supporters on Facebook",
or like, "I'm not going to
follow anyone on Twitter
who likes Hillary Clinton".
And, so I feel like my
job, is to introduce people
to each other a little bit,
and to do that you have
to really take what people are
saying seriously, the best you can.
I think a hand, but no
face attached to it.
OK.
>> In English class,
we learned how to write
from [inaudible] perspectives,
and I think that [inaudible]
and say [inaudible] unless you
understand how they are feeling
and maybe [inaudible].
>> Monica Hesse: Did it work?
Do you feel like it worked?
>> Yes.
>> Monica Hesse: OK.
what was the assignment, were you
writing about a particular issue?
>> Well we did three different
assignments - well, four,
we were like practicing for a test
so we did one from a perspective
of a boy [inaudible] and
we were trying to see --
[ Inaudible ]
>> Monica Hesse: Yes, which
totally goes back to what I was kind
of trying to say in the beginning
with what led to this book,
is that is really easy
to look back and say,
"why did they act like that?
Why didn't more people stand up?
Why didn't more people help them?
And yes.
>> Was this [inaudible]
than the other books.
>> Monica Hesse: Well, my other
books were science fiction,
so my other books didn't
need as much research,
and this needed a lot of research.
So, that was different.
And maybe easier in some ways,
because whenever I was like,
"I don't know what happens next?"
I could go to historical sources,
and they would sometimes
tell me what happened,
like around this time,
there was a big round of it,
and that maybe I should
incorporate that into story,
and that would be really
-- it was really good.
Yes.
>> [Inaudible] question
[inaudible] girl with the blue coat,
I can't help to think
about the movie [inaudible]
and that one thing
[inaudible] was lost.
Did you make a connection with that
when you came up with the title?
>> Monica Hesse: I have such
disappointing news about the title.
I did not come up with it, and
it was not my first choice,
it was just kind of like, came
out of a brainstorming session.
So, I talked to a school a few
weeks ago, and they were like,
"we've been doing essays about
the meaning of the title",
and I was like "there is no meaning
about the tittle" I feel so bad.
Yes. Yes.
>> Going back to writing from
someone else's point of view,
we also did a quick time
writing, were we looked at a photo
from during when integration
first started happening.
I think it was [inaudible]
and there was --
we had to write first
from the perspective
of the African American
girl, who's going to school,
and it was just three minute
writing, so it was like really fast,
and, that for most of
us, it was pretty easy
to interpret what she was feeling
because, is like you could relate
to her because people had been like
-- you could think of like also,
like when you are learning bad
[phonetic] history, you are thinking
of all of the -- how hard it was,
so you learn a lot about that.
And then, we had to do -- write
from the perspective of the other --
this one girl at her school who was
screaming at her in this photo --
>> Monica Hesse: I bet
that was really hard.
>> It was so difficult just to
think of what she was thinking,
and you are just like,
why would she --
I had no idea, and just
to come up with something,
for what she was thinking,
which was so difficult,
but I also think it was
a really good exercise.
So, that was sort of --
>> Monica Hesse: Yes, I know
the photo you are talking about,
and someone actually -- do
you guys know this photo?
Does that ring a bell?
It's a really powerful hard to look
at a photo of this young girl trying
to just go to school and
been yelled at and spited
on by these angry other students.
I did read interviews with some
of the other people in that photo,
they went back and found
them, like 50 years later.
And they found that screaming
woman, and she was --
[inaudible] by her
behavior, and felt as terrible
about it as she should have.
And so, we could at list take a
lesson in that, sometimes people
who even make the worst
mistakes you can imagine, learn.
Yes. Yes.
>> So, have you ever --
at the beginning you said how
you were writing about a time,
a while ago, but you realized that
you were really writing about stuff
that was going on today in a
way, because they connected --
and I know you said you
also wrote science fiction.
So, I've read a lot of
science fiction and is always
like very futuristic and very
different and whatever, but then,
when you think back to it, there
are all this perfect society that's
trying to be built and it seems
similar to what it's trying
to be built along -- what was trying
to be built during the Holocaust.
So, did you ever think
about anything like --
because you typically [inaudible]
science fiction writer that,
or you have been science fiction
writer, that you sort of are trying
to build this utopian
society and then figure
out like a different
perspective on the Holocaust?
>> Monica Hesse: Yes, I think
that that's a really
smart connection to make.
I mean, I was not thinking
when I wrote the [inaudible]
science fiction novel.
I was not thinking in any particular
time, in world or American history.
But, I think that, a pattern
in science fiction is we see people
trying to build perfect societies
that fail because their premises
is just so completely flawed.
And we do see that in the
United States, in the world,
we see people saying, "things will
be better if only we could do this,
and do this", and then,
whatever this is,
they take it to a crazy extreme.
So, I think that's a
really smart connection.
>> I think we have time
for one more question.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Monica Hesse: Definitely.
I mean, I was just reading --
have any of you guys read
or heard of "1,000 floor"?
OK. It's a really popular
book for teenagers right now,
and I keep hearing people talk
about it, so, I decided to read it
and I was so conflicted because, I
was, oh this plot is so interesting,
but, this writing, I'm just, really
not connecting with the writing.
And, I think, the best books
are ones where you like both,
and where you honestly don't
even think about how is written
because it feels natural,
and it doesn't feel forced.
So, I like that, I
like those two grades,
because those are equally important
things that kind of have to work.
Is in here?
Do you want me to tell -- ?
>> Before we thank Monica, I just
want to make one other thank you
which is to an Open Book Foundation,
that is providing books for all
of you, [inaudible] with you,
and I want to thank you
for a wonderful program.
>> Monica Hesse: Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
You guys are awesome.
[Applause]
>> This has been a
presentation from the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.